alice schwarzer polarisiert für die
einen ist sie die grand dame des
feminismus für die anderen ist sie ein
macho in frauenkleidern seit jahrzehnten
zieht schwarzer für die rechte der
frauen ins feld erst letzten herbst war
sie es die die große debatte anstieß
soll prostitution strafbar sein für
männer ja oder nein soll sex wirklich
ein konsumgut bleiben wie jeder andere
dienstleistung auch alle schwarzer sieht
er rot prostitution ist für sie moderne
sklaverei unsinn wie dann darauf sogar
feministinnen nun mit alice schwarzer
lässt sich trefflich streiten und unter
anderem über männer reden alles
schwarzer ist zu gast bei walfleisch
alice schwarzer wenn man nicht regieren
ließ merkt man da gibt's einig ein thema
das immer umkreist wird nämlich die
machtfrage
sie selber sind eine sehr mächtige frau
ist das ein problem für sie
nein es ist dagegen macht an sich nichts
zu sagen das problem ist machtmissbrauch
und wenn man wissen sie so wie ich die
verhältnisse ändern will dann braucht
man ein bisschen macht aber es hält sich
dann auch in grenzen mit der macht ich
habe sozusagen die macht der schreiberin
und des veröffentlichungs des bert
machens gut ich habe eine öffentliche
stimme
das haben sie tatsächlich so schaffen
sie auch immer wieder richtige debatte
loszutreten und eine debatte die sie
wieder losgetreten haben ist diejenige
gegen die prostitution
sie haben ein buch herausgegeben
prostitution ein deutscher skandal und
in der emma gab es einen appell wir
folgen prostitution abschaffen dieser
appell wurde von sehr vielen leuten
unterzeichnet warum haben sie eigentlich
gerade jetzt diese debatte um die
prostitution wieder hervorgekramt ja
also leider ist die position ja nicht
nur in deutschland sondern auch in
schweizer skandal und ein weltweiter in
unseren ländern wären wir sicherlich
darauf kommen die ema hat von ihrer
ersten ausgabe am
1977 gegengehalten gegen die
verharmlosung und mystifizierung oder
gar also im namen des fortschritts
position da und ein beruf jeder andere
es war immer ein thema für uns das heißt
wir waren immer an der seite von
prostituierten als feministin
solidarisch mit prostituierten aber
gegen die prostitution das system der
prostitution und ihre profiteure und in
deutschland haben wir hat rot-grün die
fortschrittlichen haben 2002 ein gesetz
erlassen das angeblich den frauen in der
position helfen sollte was sehr gut
gewesen wäre die haben wirklich hilfe
nötig schutz und angebote zum ausstieg
was ich aber als ideal erwiesen hat für
zuhälter und menschenhändler also heute
ist deutschland das el dorado in
westeuropa der menschenhändler die
drehscheibe und es gibt kaum noch
möglichkeiten für die position für die
justiz irgendwie zu intervenieren
menschenhandels entdecken usw
und da haben wir jetzt vor ungefähr
einem jahr angefangen systematisch zu
sagen worum geht es ja eigentlich also
ist eine kampagne gemacht und dieser
appell ist der höhepunkt der kampagne
genau und der wurde auslegen von vielen
berühmten persönlichkeiten unterzeichnet
margot käßmann war darunter reinhard mey
senta berger den wissenschaftler also
quer so genau was frauen männer was
fordern sie kurzfristig fordern wir und
das haben wir schon erreicht das ist im
gange die änderung dieses skandalösen
gesetzes das nur hin zu halten und den
menschenhändlern nutzt und die frauen
mehr auslieferten ihr zuvor schon drei
wochen das ist wirklich die
erfolgreichste kampagne in der
geschichte von emma drei wochen nach
erscheinen dieses heftes hat ja in den
koalitionsverhandlungen haben spd und
cdu also union beschlossen dieses gesetz
zu ändern es gibt ein großes
problembewusstsein schon dafür
und da wollen wir zum beispiel der
feuerwehr für das neue gesetz dinge wie
dass frauen unter 21 sich nicht
passieren dürfen dass es wieder eine
anmeldepflicht gibt damit man überhaupt
weiß wer ist im land 95 prozent der
frauen ihre position bei uns sind ja
ausländerinnen oft aus ganz arm ländern
dir eingeschleust werden und in der
illegalität sind die oft gar nicht die
von einem bordell zum nächsten verladen
werden die oft gar nicht wissen in
welcher stadt sie sind die kein wort
deutsch können anmeldepflicht als die
gesundheit zur untersuchung wieder damit
die frauen bestraft unter vorjahr ja
natürlich
ja das ist der provokante kern
wir fordern die bestrafung der freie
weil die feier schaffen ja überhaupt
erst den markt und ich denke mit dieser
forderung haben wir schon jetzt erreicht
dass man anfängt ein unrechtsbewusstsein
zu haben dass man sich sagt moment man
vielleicht ist das ja nicht
selbstverständlich dass ein mann einen
schein hinlegt und dafür den körper und
die seele einer frau anfassen kann um
noch zu sagen in skandinavien schweden
usw und in frankreich gerade eingeführt
werden die freiheit bestrafen
bei uns das ist klar wird das gesetz
jetzt noch nicht uneingeschränkt
eingeführt wir sind noch nicht so wir
brauchen noch einen diskussionsprozess
sprechen wir doch nachher über die
gesetzlichen grundlagen sprechen wir
zuerst noch einmal genau über diese
aussage von ihnen es braucht ein
unrechtsbewusstsein also prostitution
ist ein unrecht für sie gibt es denn den
einvernehmlichen sex gegen geld für sie
gar nicht ja was heißt ein film sex
gegen geld wissen sie menschen sind
keine ware also wir sind ja hier ist
aller philosophie nicht wir sind ja die
an einer philosophischen wenn du sehen
wir sehr grundsätzlich darüber
diddy diddy toleranz oder gar akzeptanz
und förderung von prostitution dieses
problem haben wir ja heute in unseren
dann ist ein skandal weil sie akzeptiert
dass man den menschen zur ware macht und
auch sexualität ist keine ware
und was heißt denn einvernehmlich wissen
sie wenn ein mann bezahlt dafür eine
frau dass er sie penetrieren kann sie
anfangen kann sie benutzen kann
da kann man von einvernehmlichkeit kein
regel sein und sie sind sehr war eine
frau können sich vorstellen ich mein
denken sie das einfach mal zu ende
dass sie sagen für 50 euro oder 30
manchmal sogar zählen je nachdem wie
dringlich das ist und woher sie kommen
und wo sie stehen kann es losgehen
das ist doch klar dass es ein skandal
ist aber lassen sie uns da noch länger
darüber sprechen diese
einvernehmlichkeit im grunde genommen
geht es ja nicht um die frage was ist
eigentlich freiwillig was tun wir
freiwillig jetzt könnte ich ja sagen na
ja es gibt auch manchen job von dem
denken wir nicht viele würden das
vielleicht wirklich freiwillig tun
trotzdem führen wir keine debatte
darüber also was ich jetzt genau der
unterschied zwischen bezahlen 46 oder
sagen wir mal
wir bezahlen dafür dass frauen ganz ganz
langer arbeitstag in fabriken haben dass
männer aus dem bau schuften ich war
schon einer fabrik aber ich habe mich
noch nie postiert und meine fantasie
reicht und mein einfühlungsvermögen um
den unterschied vorzustellen und sie
müssen wissen sie dieses gerede von der
freiwilligkeit ich finde es einfach
zynisch und das ist ein luxusproblem
95 prozent der frauen in der
prostitution heute in deutschland wird
er schließlich andere seien komme aus
den ärmsten ländern immer aus den
jeweils ärmsten ländern
zurzeit sind die ärmsten länder bei uns
die erreichbar gut erreichbar sind wo es
auch nicht teuer ist die ware zu
transportieren und die ich eventuell
unterwegs auf der strecke bleibt ja die
ärmsten länder sind rumänien und
bulgarien auch noch ein bisschen
russland und das sind dann frauen die im
schlimmsten fall im engsten sinne
zwangsprostituierte sind also wirklich
mit zwang dahinter sozusagen
menschenhändler so aber zu 100 prozent
diese frauenarmut prostituierte sind und
die werden entweder von schleppern
gebracht ja oft auch von ihren es sind
oft roma-familien von ihren eigenen
familien größten elend leben also es ist
immer frauen kommen immer aus dem
größten elend so die werden von ihren
eigenen familien geschickt manchmal von
ihren brüdern cousins begleitet die dann
kassieren
die frauen haben alle zuhälter und
dieses gerede von der freiwilligkeit
da gibt es also heute noch drei bis fünf
prozent deutsche post trier die in der
mehrheit so genannte alte uhren sind
auch scheußliches wort die selber
studios haben und die selber diese
dieses frischfleisch wie es in der
branche heißt es hat das alles dass er
eine abgründigkeit die man sich gar
nicht vorstellen kann
die die frauen selber verkaufen also und
wir reden ja auch nicht wir lassen ja
auch nicht zu sie haben das gerade schon
kurz gestreift was heißt hier eigentlich
freiwillig also zb bei uns ist die
leihmutterschaft verboten
bei uns ist es verboten dass ein
gesunder mensch organe verkauft ware
geld braucht auch wenn uns freiwillig
tut ja das ist eine ethische frage für
uns wir sagen du kannst ja nicht deinen
körper verstümmeln und nur weil du geld
brauchst das wollen wir nicht dann
müssen wir schauen dass wir anders
helfen können und dasselbe ist die
prostitution
naja ob es das selbe ist da müsste man
wahrscheinlich nochmal lange darüber
reden und sie vielleicht sichtlich
stimme stimmen die sagen genau diese
verbote wären eigentlich verkehrt man
müsste auch diese verbote aufheben weil
eben mein bauch gehört mir das
eigentlich beim aus dessen damit gar
nichts zu tun hat damit ganz möchte ihm
was zu verboten sagen wissen sie eine
gesellschaft wenn sie friedlich zusammen
muss sich regeln geben und zu diesem
regeln gehören selbst wahrscheinlich
auch verbote und gesetze
wir leben zusammen und wenn sie nicht
wollen dass das gesetz des stärkeren
herrscht wenn sie nicht ausgehen an der
limmat lang und einer haut immer so auf
den kopf weil er stärker ist und da
kümmert sich niemand darum wolle gerade
bock drauf hatte oder weil er etwas
wegnimmt
also natürlich andere regeln natürlich
haben wir gesetze natürlich haben wir
geboten
das regelt unser zusammenleben und so
denke ich dass perspektivisch man kann
prostitution die wendung schon ziemlich
lange haben und die etwas strukturelles
es ist ja auch gleitend nicht wo fängt
es an wo hört es ausgibt diese
vielzitierten alle von ihnen zitierten
jungen damen die die die schon bereit
sind dafür dass sie sich was schickes
kaufen können sich mal gelegenheit zu
postieren aber den schaden den sie davon
nehmen wie viele stehen sie dann auf
vater das sind ja lauter eigentlich
empirische untersuchungen die wir
bräuchten und da gibt es einfach sehr
sehr viel widersprüchliche daten es gibt
auch sehr viele artikel die ich gelesen
habe da werden genau andere daten
gebracht da heißt es erst wieder viele
frauen wollen das auch tun
ich sage ihnen nur eine zahl ich weiß
dass sie in einem artikel gesagt haben
ungefähr 90 prozent der prostituierten
in deutschland möchten gerne aussteigen
martha wigger das ist eine leiterin
einer beratungsstelle für
sexarbeiterinnen bern ja sicher weiteren
schauen so ist dieser begriff wollen ja
auch wissen dass ich vielleicht was soll
denn der spieler soll dann diese alberne
geschafft mit den mitgebrachten zahlen
nein nein ich kann die gerne auf seite
lassen gehen sie doch einfach mal zu den
verrichtungsboxen gehen sie doch mal hin
zum frustrierten werden sie nicht mit
einer edel [ __ ] die selber ein kleines
studio ein und die forschungsstelle da
kann eben beratungsstellen die sind auch
bei uns ein großes problem
wissen sie in deutschland werden zurzeit
aber eigentlich ist es keine ebene wie
wichtig war sich interessant finde weil
wir sind jetzt schon woanders
wir sind schon dabei ich habe gerade die
französische frau ministerin interviewt
für immer für die nächste ausgabe
ja und in frankreich ist es
selbstverständlich dass man im
zusammenhang mit der prostitution über
die frage der menschenwürde spricht wir
reden hier von menschenwürde
mein anliegen ist es nur also genau wir
sind in einer sternstunde philosophie
klare unterscheidungen zu treffen liegt
eigentlich wirklich an der prostitution
oder liegt es an den arbeitsbedingungen
lassen sie mich das ganz kurz erklären
entsetzlich nein ich habe für ihn schon
zu hören aber bitte
sie wollen schöne schicke prostituierte
mit ja in hübschen räumen mit mir es
gäbe nicht darunter
ich denke er macht das nicht ich möchte
nicht sagen dass ich dass ich das möchte
dass ich das mit nein oder davon reden
sie genau ich möchte gerne die
unterscheidung hinkriegen liegt sagen
nicht daran dass diese prostituierten
zum teil unter grauenhaften bedingungen
leben
wir brauchen nicht darüber zu
diskutieren ob menschen haben die in
ordnung ist das ist wirklich keine
diskussion darüber auch keine diskussion
darüber dass wir wissen dass die preise
auf den strich plätzen extrem zusammen
gefahren sind wir haben auch in der
schweiz total die situation dass die
jungen frauen für 20 franken
sex ohne verhütung anbieten müssen schon
in zehn teilen sehen oder 20 bei freier
pro nacht bedienen müssen dass ihm
zustände
da gehe ich völlig einig mit ihnen das
wollen wir nicht das können wir nicht
tolerieren das ist schrecklich was wir
dagegen tun müssen ist ja noch mal eine
andere frage aber aus ethischer sicht
finde ich auch gibt es keine diskussion
aber was ist mit den prostituierten die
tatsächlich natürlich die ich
entscheiden dass das für sie eine gute
sache ist die sagen jetzt die irren sich
einfach das gibt es nicht aber woher
wissen wir das eigentlich ich hatte nur
zurück damit zu urteilen darüber was
anderes
ich hatte mich nicht zurück insofern sie
mir das mal was interessiert mich
nämlich ja ich versuche zu uns ja auch
die schöne position die sie im verhalten
es gibt stellen sie sie sind journalist
und sie sitzen ja sie machen fernsehen
sie kriegen das angemessen bezahlt
stellen sie sich mal vor sie ein
callgirl dann gibt es natürlich junge
frauen die erst mal denken
wir wissen das ja aus dem lebenslauf und
es gibt eine menge erkenntnisse wir sind
nicht so ohne informationen und diese
erkenntnisse decken sich auch alle
internationalen wir wissen aus den
lebensläufen dass eine überwältigende
mehrheit von den frauen die freiwillig
in der position sind das heißt die nicht
von schleppern aus bulgarien gebracht
werden oder von ihren familien
hingeschickt werden und immer anschaffen
müssen dass die noch häufiger als als im
statistischen durchschnitt in der
kindheit sexuellen missbrauch erfahren
haben wir haben ja auch in dieser
vorletzten immer oder oder oder im buch
ist das ein wirklich viele sehr
differenziertes gespräch mit zwei
sogenannten freiwilligen prostituierten
aus wersen ja eine eine ganz junge frau
und eine mittvierzigerin schon sehr
bewusst und beide sagen auf ihre art
etwas ähnliches
sie sagen auch die junge frau die frist
vom vater missbraucht worden kommt ja
auch öfter vor ist und die andere so und
beide sagen ich habe erst mal gedacht so
was ich jetzt mache ich das mal für geld
und jetzt bin ich herren der lage
jetzt sag ich mal hier da geht's lang
und und dann machen wir das eins war da
ja und dann wenn sie kaputt nicht also
die ältere und auch die junge die sagen
wir sind da reingerutscht wir haben
gedacht wir haben es im griff und es
wird nie mehr so sein wie vorher ihrer
sexualität ist natürlich auch zerstört
verstehen sie wie wollen sie denn wenn
sie vorher das geliefert haben viel geld
wie es ist ja alles angefasst und
belastet alle fotografien mit der wir
arbeiten hat in war ja im frühling im
letzten frühling war sie bettina finder
war sie neun tage oder zehn tage in
einem luxushotel soll modell wo sie
denken mensch also das doch toll wenn es
wunderbar alles sauber und so weiter
übrigens fast keinen 1 2 konnte nur
deutsch und sind alle noch ein paar
wochen da und werden dann woanders hin
verlagern
ja so in ihrem fein schönen bordell und
diese fotografien hat fire fotografiert
wir sind inzwischen in deutschland so
weit dass manche männer denn ist es noch
nicht mehr peinlich ja in der
verheiratete dabei junge gut genau wie
taufe und sie heimlich fotografiert und
hat sie gefragt warum tun sie das
alle haben mit unterschiedlichen
variationen bei allen war klar es ist
eine machtfrage
sie haben keinen bock mit den frauen zu
verhandeln sie haben keinen bock sie
erst einzuladen und geld auszugeben dann
wird doch nichts draus oder die eigene
freundin oder frau will nicht und statt
sozusagen auch es ist das ist eine macht
haben worauf ich jetzt raus will ist
wenn wir ihre position reden reden wir
nicht nur über die frauen ende
prostitution die direkt betroffen sind
und die männer gehen ja auch unrecht
getan wird junge männer die in eine welt
hinein wachsen wo man sagt du bist kein
problem lg zu den nächsten tag macht die
beine breit hier scheint schluss denn
wir liegen über uns alle was richten wir
denn an in den köpfen von frauen im
männern wenn wir das verharmlosen wenn
wir männern möglich machen auszuweichen
nach dem start wieder abzutrennen vom
gefühl abzutrennen von beziehung wie
kommen denn diese feier nach hause
nicht nur eventuell mit aids weil zu
nehmen wollen die männer ohne kondome
nicht sondern sie kommen auch mit einer
vorstellung der sexualität nach hause
die natürlich jede beziehung
überschattet gut das sind jetzt wiederum
für mich empirischer namen von denen ich
nicht recht weiß auch lassen dürfen auch
noch ohne statistiken ihren verstand
gerade als philosophie in gang setzen
dürfen einfach mal so etwas interessiert
mich immer noch weil ich noch nicht
verstanden habe was für sie genau die
differenz ist nämlich noch einmal ein
beispiel es gibt viele frauen ist
eigentlich schade dass wir so lange
rennen ich habe es gesagt positionen so
sagt es das elend nämlich eine frau die
kommt aus der dominikanischen republik
wer möchte gerne ihre kinder zuhause
finanzieren
kommt in die schweiz sie hat zwei
möglichkeiten sie kann sich entweder als
reinigungskraft darstellen oder als
prostituierte als prostituierte verdient
sie weitaus mehr geld die entscheidet
sich dafür mache diesen job geht es war
nach hause
ich weiß das ist furchtbar es ist
entsetzt richtig auf den bilder wirklich
sagen zu überschnitt erste unterschied
erstens die dominikanerin ja die sich
prostituiert die wird in der regel 99
von 100 fällen liebe kollegin abkassiert
ich war sie das leben kennen wir reden
hier vom leben nicht von irgendwelchen
fantasien die wird abkassiert
sie hatten mal eine exzellente reportage
von einem schweizer journalisten die wir
nach gedruckt haben
da hat genau so einem fall mal
aufgedröselt wie die ihm geschleppt
worden die hat noch weniger wissen sie
was der durchschnitt stundenlohn ist von
nein ich sage ihnen jetzt das war der
anteil mit der putzfrau kommen und sie
können sich ja auch mal für sich
überlegen sind ja auch nur eine frau
genau wie ich danke ich überlegen ob sie
die beim putzen oder sich postulieren
und ich kann ihnen schon sagen sie
sollten lieber putzen weil sie da mehr
verdienen der durchschnittslohn und das
sagen sogar sogenannte hohen projekte in
deutschland den ich den ausstieg
propagieren den einstieg wir sind
nämlich alle völlig unterwandert von
zuhältern und menschenhändlern das sage
ich in aller gelassenheit das kann man
bei uns nachlesen
der durchschnitt stundenlohn ist fünf
euro okay auch bei flatrates und um
diese fünf euro zu kriegen müssen sie in
12 stunden ganz ordentlich männer über
sich drüber lassen denn sie müssen
abliefern sie müssen abliefern
bei den schicken legalen
bordellbetreiber ja da bin ich schon
überhaupt rein zu kommen schon oder ein
zimmer zu haben
kleine zimmerchen von ich weiß nicht
firma vier quadratmetern alte hupen
kaufhäusern kosten 180 euro am tag in
deutschland bei ihnen wird es nicht
anders sein
stellen sich dass man vor bisschen die
angeschafft haben diese 180 jetzt regen
werden auch nicht von den zuhälter oder
cosan der draußen steht und sagt hier
und wir reden auch noch nicht von dem
geld
dass diese frauen nach hause schicken
müssen sie werden auch von ihren oft vom
eigenen familien erpresst die haben
manchmal kleine kinder da wir reden
einfach vom leben
wissen sie ich kann dieses logische in
spritze biete ideologische gesetze nicht
mehr hören und sie können einfach
versuchen sich in die situation anders
als heute versetzen ich kann
ein arbeiter habe ich mit prostituierten
gesprochen
das ist nicht neu für mich das thema
aber so erstmal im bordell war ich 1965
aber es gibt ja auch diese vereinigungen
dollar kamen zb die gewöhnlich die sie
die sie angreifen und die sagen sie
hören in japan oder sie würden einfach
alles über einen kamm scheren und ihre
leichte darauf über den körper selbst ja
also dann kam dollar kamen ist wie nun
hinlänglich belegt ist ein interessen
und das hat sie auch selber
interessenvertreterin der modell
industrie was wollen sie denn eigentlich
noch
sie konnten noch nicht gemacht spiel
sozusagen das heißt das also
diddy diddy diddy positions- industrie
schickt frauen nach vorne
die sagen wir finden dass schick donner
carmen hat mit das schlimmste aber sie
sind alle übel
er hat als vor zwei jahren der skandal
mit der flatrate hoch kann ja wissen wir
ganz kurz erklären zwar echt ist man
zahlt 30 oder 40 50 euro und kann den
ganzen tag bumsen so lange und so viel
man will und bei diesem flatrates sind
die männer in horden über die frauen
hergefallen
ab morgens so dass die nach eigenen
aussagen schon wir sind jetzt mal
konkret ja nicht so fallen
schon gegen mittag schon völlig und wahn
und wein da saßen und nicht mehr konnten
die diese flatrate da haben dann doch
die meisten menschen gleich gesagt
kinder das kann nicht sein dass du so
waren der schweiz hat kam auch eine
petition veröffentlicht an die kanzlerin
geschrieben und geschrieben flatrate ist
ganz toll und übrigens von trainer kam
ist die zahl fünf euro in der stunde
also bitte kann aber sagen da ist putzen
aber gold gegen eine andere frage und
wir müssen ja auch die frauenschützen
wir können hier nicht
der markt wird ja immer größer dadurch
dass prostitution gesellschaftsfähig
geworden ist wird der markt immer größer
und es werden immer mehr frauen wie
gesagt die meistens kein wort deutsch
können völlig abhängig sind nicht wissen
in welcher stadt sie sind werden
reingepumpt in unserer länder und immer
mehr männer werden verführt ich finde es
auch 1 kann beide männern gegenüber
diese das für möglich zu halten wissen
sie zum beispiel die französische frau
ministerin hat mir gesagt in der letzten
woche dass allein durch die debatte das
gesetz wird ja im märz verabschiedet
allein durch die debatte über die
prostitution hat der prostitution markt
nach aussagen der der menschen die immer
treiben
ein einbruch von 40 prozent das doch
großartig
männer werden nachdenklich wenn es denn
wirklich dass das verbot was bringt aber
darüber möchte ich noch entsprechend ich
auch noch eine frage an sie sind daher
nicht die männlichen callboys die
strippe sind diese sie genauso
schutzbedürftig und selbstverständlich
also keine frage des biologischen
geschlecht ist also sie fahren eine eine
abschaffung der prostitution für männer
wie für frauen ja doch
selbstverständlich natürlich hat mich
nur interessiert weil ich natürlich in
erster linie wert nahe und so erwähnt
aber die frauen sind die mehrheit aber
selbstverständlich aber sie bieten das
ist eigentlich das gleiche als wenn eine
frau an einem callboy kommen lässt dann
ist es risiken
das ist nett dass sie eine frau denken
normalerweise bestehen männer kolben das
ist richtig aber und sie zeigen wir
bereit stehen mir mal bitte eine frau
wie in kolm bestellt wissen was frauen
machen die bestellen sich escort männer
schon mal wenn sie reich sind ja die sie
begleiten beim ausgehen und so weiter
und die mit ihnen nicht sein sollen
galant und flirten die prostitutions
machtverhältnis lässt sich nicht einfach
umdrehen
also sie denken es gibt keine frau die
einfach nur um den puren sex wählen man
bestellt
es gibt vielleicht ein paar aber die
sind von so verschwinden relevant das
ist nicht der punkt
über die gesetzliche grundlage haben
jetzt schon ein paar mal angesprochen
ich habe ja eine karte damit ihr das
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
sie wissen das ja hinlänglich aber das
ist uns einmal vor augen führen roth die
länder in denen die prostitution
verboten ist grün die länder indem sie
eben legalisiert ist und gelb
eingeschränkt haben es auch erwähnt
frankreich ist am kippen
da wird der senat jetzt noch einmal über
einen gesetzesvorschlag auch rein
debattieren
ja die habe ich lady gaga ist die charta
sichert sich wir können immer dasselbe
reden jetzt über wir haben vielleicht
aber noch andere themen ja gerade ist
falsch also zum beispiel in frankreich
java prostitution
das ist ein aber ich habe mir das wort
nicht sagen evolution ist genau das
anschaffen möchte dass grundsätzlich
frankreich hatte noch nie eine andere
haltung in frankreich sind proteste
verboten genau in vielen ländern die
gelb sind ja die bordelle verboten sie
hier auch ja so und jetzt macht
frankreich den schritt und geht auf das
schwedische modell wissen sie dass in
schweden
es geht ja bei dieser ganzen debatte um
zwei dinge es geht um ganz konkrete
gesetze zum schutz von frauen und zur
verfolgung von verbrechern
es geht aber auch um die symbolische
bedeutung dieser gesetze dass eine
gesellschaft hat was sie recht und was
ihr unrecht findet und zb in schweden
ich bin gerade ganz bis über gewürzen in
der debatte ich habe gerade gestern mit
schweden geredet in berlin ist es so die
haben glaube ich seit 15 jahren was also
ziemlich lange zeit schon das
feierverbot das dass das bewusstsein der
menschen geändert hat 80 prozent aller
schwedischen frauen und männer sind
heute gegen prostitution sie
als menschenunwürdig und übrigens was
ich auch interessant finde reden wir mal
von den männern seit ich wieder in die
offensive gegangen bin zu den problemen
seit rund einem jahr
da war ich in der fernsehsendung und so
weiter und sein immer wieder sozusagen
die kampagne gemacht hat bekomme ich
mehr briefe von männern als von frauen
das ist doch etwas ja das sind
zustimmende briefe eher zu- als um einen
die zurückhaltung der frauen
ich habe das gefühl frauen haben angst
sich zu dem thema zu äußern
sie haben angst als prüde zu gelten
sie wollen sich bei männern anbeten
indem sie cool und offen sind und ich
finde nichts dabei ich kann den lieben
frauen so sagen sie täuschen sich ich
glaube die männer finden das gar nicht
gut in die männer wissen was das ist
diese männer sind entweder mal junge
männer die auf recht empört sind also
söhne der des feminismus der
emanzipation seid ja unerhört und so
weiter es sind aber auch ältere
lebenserfahrene männer die müssen jetzt
die schreiben wie auslieferungsfahrzeug
begeisterung reden ja auch schon ein
paar mal im bordell
ja aber jetzt sagen sie mal wo soll ich
denn am sinnvollsten spenden deshalb
männer die um gedacht haben und das ist
für mich ein großer sieg
ich möchte einfach menschenwürdige
verhältnisse zwischen den geschlechtern
frauen dürfen nicht länger das käufliche
geschlecht sein denn wenn man das kann
wissen sie dann kommt natürlich der dazu
verführte mann ehefrau so an was kostet
denn oder er lässt während er seine
chefin anguckt so den pornofilm kopf
laufen auf diesel galle handeln will
auch eigentlich nur von hinten kommen
werden uns also die was so rein gedrückt
wird in die fantasien und dagegen müssen
wir angehen und denken sie ein verbot
ist der richtige weg die sagen jetzt es
geht um die signalwirkung das ist dass
einige gesellschaftspolitische haltung
die man sozusagen verteidigt mit einem
verbot das andere ist ja wirklich das
reale leben der prostituierten und da
gibt's auch unterschiedliche zahlen
viele sagen auch zahlen zu publizieren
ist immer sehr schwierig die schwedische
regierung spricht ja wirklich auch davon
dass mindestens 50 prozent der
prostitution zurückgegangen ist
vielleicht sogar mehr
andererseits weiß man eine wirkliche
buße eine gefängnisstrafe oder so etwas
dennoch fast nie verhängt es gibt immer
wieder staatsangehörigen worden das sind
nein aber jetzt denn wirklich also per
gesetz etwas ja ich habe es ihnen noch
eben gesagt das hat sich total das
bewusstsein in schweden geändert und es
geht auch nicht nur um verbote nicht in
schweden nicht in frankreich nicht bei
unserem das erste ist schutz für die
frauen in der prostitution hilfe zum
ausstieg ein fachausschuss schutz also
primitiv schutz angefangen mit schutz
vor vor vor ansteckungen vor aets also
zum beispiel prostituierte die durch
deutschland geschleust worden sind und
dann nach österreich kommen zum beispiel
hören der von österreich dass die
besonders krank sind weil die besonders
ausgeliefert sind die haben keine
gesundheitskontrolle mehr die freier
zwingen erzwingen dass man ohne kondome
usw
es geht um schutz und hilfe für frauen
in der prostitution und dann geht es um
verfolgung der profiteure der profiteure
zuhälter oder meinen sie jetzt auch die
freier mann der da kommen wir jetzt zum
freier erst mal ist der profiteur der
menschenhändler der zuhälter und die
legale bordell betreiber die inzwischen
schon an die börse gehen weil sie
natürlich profitraten haben das an ganz
schwindelig wird vor freude wenn man am
profitraten interessiert ist stellen
sich vor einen 880 mal 30 können sich
ausrechnen was man mir zum vier mal vier
quadratmeter raum verdient in dem
gewerbe so die die freie
denn die will ich nicht profitieren die
freier sind einfach die andere hälfte
den auch unrecht getan wird ich glaube
dass von 100 prozent frei die wir in
unserer laissez faire gesellschaft haben
dass wenn wir wirklich kritisch und
ehrlich und nachdenklich reden über das
system prostitution und was dazwischen
genannten frauen passiert dass wir
irgendwann dass 80 bis 90 prozent
verzichten und das ein harter kern
bleibt von 10 bis 20 prozent
die gehen dann in die illegalität oder
ins ausland und die sie nicht zu retten
und da müssen einfach schauen dass sie
aussterben und für die nachwachsenden
jungen männer ein menschenbild auch von
frauen schaffen dass es undenkbar macht
dass man sagt was kostet denn heute frau
schwarzer diesem jahr eine extrem
reflektierte und kluge frau
und oft ist es ja so wenn man etwas
richtig schlimm findet und sich überlegt
was gibt's dazu alles zu sagen dann
kommen 1000 argument in den sinn und
trotzdem wenn man einen schritt zurück
steht merkt mama ja es gibt vielleicht
gewisse punkte die muss ich den gegnern
schenken oder gewisse punkte verstehe
ich auch gibt's in der prostitution
debatte so etwas muss ich sagen ich sehe
das problem und ich lege sich sehr bei
der minderheit
ein einheimischer prostituierte also so
wie wir sie es hat ja ich glaube es gibt
keine andere publikationen wo so viele
postämter selber sprechen das ist ein
buch nicht nur über postierte das ist
richtig doch ausrangierten aber mächtig
und ich kann nachvollziehen
diese illusion dass man sagt kommen
jetzt bin ich schon habe ich in der
sexualität so viel müsste erfahren jetzt
solvenz dafür bezahlt werden und ich
bestimme die regeln
wir hören von den frauen die diese
illusion ist verstehe ich sehr gut
versteht sowieso fast alles deswegen
versteht alles das heißt nicht dass ich
alles hin immer und alles billiger und
aber wenn die frauen dann merken dass
sie eine illusion aufgesessen sind dann
ist es zu spät dann sind sie tief
geschädigt dass das eine
ich verstehe ja auch manche freiherr die
sorgen auch notebook also immer
diskutieren und so schwierig und
emanzipation und ja wie wir sie auch
austeilen da geht es gar nicht immer nur
um sex die kaufen sich da die männer für
zwei drei wochen an ersatz ehefrau die
richtig schön weniger machen muss schön
alles nicht verwöhnen muss mit den
wimpern klimpern und sowie suchen
einfach wieder unterwerfung die sind vor
uns sind paul aber auch diesen männern
möchte ich sagen was man auf das
schadete gelegen ist ein bisschen
schwierig aber lassen wir das mal
ich möchte aber wir können aussagen des
sprechers ist schön dass sie auf diese
politische korrektheit jahres ist
reagieren ist erst mal wichtig ein punkt
noch zu diesem thema dann gehen wir
wirklich weiter elisabeth machen wir
aber nicht mehr
trotzdem ja martha nussbaum eine andere
wieder so für dich sicherheits amerika
beide sagen verbot ist falsch weil wir
eigentlich den frauen etwas was sie auch
den frauen geben wollten nämlich das
recht auf den eigenen körper das recht
weil in meinem körper zu verfügen
jeder wegnehmen das recht auf das
missbraucht des eigenen körpers ich sag
mal was zu bei den teddy eine freundin
ist und mit der ich sehr viele
gemeinsamkeiten haben
ich darf man sagen vielleicht ist dann
elisabeth badinter doch ein bisschen zu
weit weg lass ich mal richtig in ein
bordell reinkommen unter als solcher
frauen und ein bisschen zu dicht dran an
ihrer intellektuellen clique
strauss-kahn usw
entschuldigung das eine entschuldigung
die die frau strauss kahn ist an der
besten freundin elisabeth badinter das
kann vorkommen
die asha ich habe nicht alles gut was
der strauss kahn macht oder
wahrscheinlich nicht aber ich habe noch
kein kritisches wort gehört ja es gibt
frauen die tun sich schwer sich kritisch
zu äußern weil ich kann ihnen auch sagen
warum das hat seinen preis also ich
krieg auch schon drohungen oder und
andeutungen dass ich das bezahlen werde
also okay wir werden sehen
sie argumentieren montiert feministisch
ihr anliegen ist das recht der frauen
sie möchten diese ganze unterdrückung
wie sie sagen aufheben gucken wir doch
mal zurück ein bisschen auf ihr leben
sie haben ja auch ihren lebenslauf
geschrieben aber die schwarza lebenslauf
das buch was man kaufen kann
wir schauen uns spielern und zwar bilder
aus der rundschau vom zweiter november
schon 2011
ich bin schaue ich habe gar keinen vater
ich denke dass ich das lässt sich sehr
positiv ausgewirkt hat aber noch nie
und ich bin von einem mann erzogen
worden 1942 wurde klein alice geboren
beim großvater franz geborgenheit bei
der großmutter debattier freudig kite in
den 70ern entdeckt sie die
frauenbewegung der kampf gegen den
paragrafen 218 der abtreibung verbietet
wird zentral
sie trägt das anlegen von frankreich
nach deutschland als wir sagen wie gut
dass liefen das ist ein großer erfolg
war damals gesagt mein gott da sollte
eigentlich auf frankreich beschränkt
bleiben als politische korrespondentin
lebt sie in paris interviewt auch die
philosophin simone büro an der seen
begegnet sie der gründer mit den
jurastudenten brüno mit ihren artikeln
act schwarzer an anfeindungen nehmen zu
von männern und frauen
[Musik]
warum hat frau schwarz einen derartigen
haus oft die männer
es geht im frauenkampf gar nicht in
erster linie um männer
es geht beim frauenkampf in erster linie
um die frauen schwarzes bücher landen
auf der bestseller liste mit dem geld
grüezi 1977 die ema redaktion die
zeitschrift von frauen für frauen
frau schwarzer sie haben sie überhaupt
persönlich gekannt ich habe hier auch
noch einmal ein sehr eindrucksvolles
bild von ihnen beziehungen der bassist
von barbara klemm von 1978 was ist das
für eine szene hier können sie sich an
dieses gespräch erinnern
ja ich habe simon aber war ich es oder
ich bin sozusagen eine politische
weggefährtin von monaco war als wir in
paris 1970 eins zu eins zwei dutzend
frauen die frauenbewegung initiiert
haben was ja in der luft lag sind wir
irgendwann zur wahl gegangen und haben
wir alle hier sind wie
machst du mit zwar die zeit fürs haar an
der seite von jungnau ist ein kämpfte
und so weiter und dann hat geworden sagt
selbstverständlich
und es hat sich dann daraus weil wir und
politisch nahe waren wir auch emotional
eine freundschaft ergeben und ich habe
ab 1971 bis 1983 eine serie von
programmatischen interviews gesprächen
mit bow wow gemacht die auch als buch
erschienen sind und das erste war eine
sensation weil da die autoren vom
anderen geschlecht
die jahr 1949 noch damit endet dass sie
sagt also der klassenkampf so hat man
das gedacht 49 wird schon auch die
geschlechterfrage lösen
das erste mal dass sie dann gesagt hat
nein ich bin feministin frauen müssen
als frauen organisieren
auch linke männer sind machos und so
weiter und das ist eben das erste
gespräch für immer ich glaube da ging es
um den neuen weiblichkeit wagen
da sitzen wir bei ihr zu hause in diesem
wunderbaren universum dass es leider
nicht mehr gibt und reden darüber
simon huber hatte ja eine offene
zweierbeziehung mit shampoo sagt rauch
darüber weiß man ja heute einiges das
wahrscheinlich auch simon tobor ziemlich
gelitten hat unter dieser situation wenn
sie zurückblicken wie war das damals wie
sie haben sie es bewundert die die
beiden zusammen gelegt werden dass alle
bewundert für meine generation wenn man
bis drei zählen konnte war das paar das
große vorbild
sie haben gewagt sich zu politische
engagiert zu engagieren auch in sehr
schwierigen fragen gegen den
kolonialismus im algerienkrieg und so
weiter richtig mutig ja das ist ja mal
eine bombe rhein geworfen worden in die
wohnung und die hälfte verbrannt sie
habe sie war nicht verheiratet sie haben
getrennt gewohnt und sind sich eben
immer unabhängig begegnet sie sind durch
die ganze welt gereist und wo war hat
natürlich mit ihrem
und das ist nicht nur das andere
geschlecht das ist sie hat mal gesagt
mein leben ist mein werk und das ist
richtig
es ist dieses zusammenspiel von romanen
die wie bei allen schriftstellern
schriftstellerin stark autobiografisch
geprägt sind von roman membran
erinnerungen briefen usw
dass uns ein ganz fulminantes leben
zeigt und natürlich wenn man eine so
genannte offene beziehung führt ich
persönlich habe große reserven gegen
sowas bin ich viel biederen aber
trotzdem ist so toll dass ich dass
jemand traut dann gibt es auch schmerzen
aber wissen sie wo warte ich auf viele
freiheiten erlaubt wo war es keineswegs
das sei in dieser beziehung gewesen ganz
im gegenteil sei trat da eine tür
aufgestoßen
wo sie auch herausgetreten wissen und
und eine der ganz großen thesen von
zimmern demo war war ja mal wird nicht
aus frau geboren und jetzt zu einer
gemacht damit ich eigentlich in die
philosophiegeschichte auch eingegangen
wenn man die these ernst nimmt denken
sie das stimmt heute noch so ja wie
formuliert butler das also es gibt doch
nichts anderes also sex und gender oder
so also was ist noch mal ihr schlüssel
das ist ja dasselbe nur in anderen
begrifflichkeiten ja natürlich
sie können das auf studieren an
lebensläufen ich habe mir nicht zufällig
oft porträtiert oder biografien
geschrieben und dabei auch immer
nachgespürt sozusagen der der der
fabrikation der der sexuellen identität
und zb meine biographien über gräfin
dönhoff die kolleginnen und romy
schneider die gehören eigentlich
zusammen es ist einmal dönhoff die frau
mit der männlichen identität die sich
von anfang an nicht im frau seien ein
schließen lässt alles macht was männer
machen sogar ihr frau sein vielleicht
ein bisschen verleugnet verdrängt und
romy schneider die die frau an sich ist
und alle rollen durchgegangen ist
die uns in der nachkriegszeit als frauen
so angeboten wurden und ja auch sehr
früh gestorben ist in der regel zuerst
mitte 50 also sie können sehr leicht
wenn sie den lebensläufen nachspüren
sehen warum gibt es manchmal
abweichungen vom klassischen frau sein
oder man sein
sie haben eben hier mein leben zitiert
ich finde ja ich bin sehr weiblich und
auch am stück männlich zugleich das ist
übrigens auch alle oder ja auch kann
nicht nur hoffen
ich lebe das nun offensiv ausleben wenn
ich alle offensive auf die frauen ich
auch lächeln meistens zu oft und trauen
uns keine offenen kontroversen usw
also es gibt ganz typische
verhaltensweisen die zehn klassischen
verhaltensweisen sind ja heute laut der
großen internationalen psychologischen
studien immer noch dieselben was ist
männlich was es wirklich sheard
natürlich ist das geschieht aber es ist
eben auch ein stückchen realität was sie
sagen will ist an meinem leben können
sie bäder bösartig ablesen warum ich
abweichen konnte so zum einen natürlich
aufgewachsen bei großeltern da gibt es
einen größeren spielraum als sonst ein
ich erzogen pläne vor einem mann wie so
ist dann aufgewachsen in einer hoch
politisierten familie an die nation
also selbstverständlich immer über
unrecht geredet über die welt
nachgedacht und so weiter das war bei
uns am wohnzimmertisch daneben bei
diesem großeltern aufgewachsen bin eine
leichte umdrehung also ein fürsorglicher
sanfter man 11 und der großvater der
mich in der tat groß gezogen hat also
mit der flasche kann also da hab nicht
hat nicht mal da ist ich war als mehr
invention habe nach der geburt ja meine
mutter ist er gegangen ich war ja kein
wunschkind und meine großmutter war die
politische und intellektuelle autorität
und war als frau nicht einfach und
übrigens sehr destruktiv und interessant
ist wenn ich ihnen das noch sagen dass
ich natürlich dieses
einerseits hat diese interessante frau
ja aber der mann also innerhalb der
familie
der hat mich beschützt und ich habe
ihnen geschützt also im gegensatz zu dem
was man einmal von der feministisch
wasser senkt männer sind mir emotional
sehr nah und genau deshalb akzeptiere
ich nicht dass sie nicht menschlich sind
und ich weiß dass sie das sein können
und ich verstehe auch viel verdienen
etwas was mich sehr beschäftigt ist das
ja eigentlich schon so ein bisschen den
blick haben auf die frauen dass man sehr
vielen frauen im grunde genommen ein
bisschen helfen muss man muss sie
schützen die prostituierten muss man
schützen
sie finden die kopftuchträgerinnen
möchte man schützen weil die nämlich
lernen müssen ja kopftuch abzugeben
die hausfrauen die nur zu hause sein
wagen am herd die brauchen irgendwie
auch hilfe können sie verstehen dass es
frauen gibt die sagen vielen dank wir
können selber wir brauchen diese
entwicklungshilfe nicht die große bevor
man darin schwarzer die die weiß was für
frauen gut ist das haben sie ein
bisschen viel auf einmal gesagt wir sind
sie ihre generation weiß dass gleich
nicht mehr so also ich denke also
hausfrauen als will sich radikalisiert
hat meine gespräche mit frauen ab 0 71
für meine bücher und ich habe mir diesen
abgrund auch an bei hausfrauen an
verunsicherung an gar nicht mehr an sich
glauben an sich kaum noch raus trauen
anja kann ich das denn überhaupt noch
kann ich noch berufstätig sein oder auch
dass der netteste man irgendwann sagt
schatz
das hatte das kleid gekostet also
natürlich mussten wir filmen ist den mit
wucht vorgehen um diese klassische
arbeitsteilung in frage zu stellen
der mann in der welt und mit dem geld
verstehe ich komme ja auch gerade so
netten mal eben das kopftuch dass alle
ab machen sollen seien sie doch nicht so
was oberflächlich ist und polemisches
über eine so ernste sache es gibt länder
wo der wende an das kopftuch verrutscht
oder der die schar der der der
ganzkörperschleier
das kann sie das leben kosten es gibt
überhaupt länder afghanistan und so
weiter da kann eine frau nicht rausgehen
ohne ein männliches wesen und sei es
auch nur ihr sohn der musik in der
wohnung bleiben
das kopftuch das islamische kopftuch
nicht dass der deutschen oder schweizer
bäuerin kopftuch ja sondern das
islamische kopftuch das alles verdeckt
weil derweil weil das der körper und das
haar sünde ist sünde und wenn ein mann
ein mädchen oder eine frau sieht springt
dann direkt drauf weil es ja ein tier
ist dass ich dann nicht mehr
zurückhalten kann man muss sich auch mal
das männerbild überlegen dieses kopftuch
ist natürlich ein politikum das jetzt
nicht verstanden gegen das kopftuch
zusammen mit dem tier auf das man drauf
springen kann
wir wissen sie nicht warum befinden sie
ja nicht warum das islamische kopftuch
verdeckt das haar und den körper weil
das sünde ist der frauenkörper ist sünde
das habe so das ist die wird behauptet
ja und wenn der mann darf also die frau
so nicht sehen sonst ist ja nicht mehr
zu halten ist natürlich auch ein fatales
männerbild dieses kopftuch das eben
tyrannisches gesetze ist in den
islamistisch beherrschten ländern und
die frauen wird sich blutig unterdrückt
ja dieses kopftuch ist ein politikum und
kein kleidungsstück und dass wir jetzt
das problem haben dass wir dieses
kopftuch auch mitten in europa haben
da müssen wir darüber reden können also
zum einen die frauen und mädchen die
freiwillig das islamische kopftuch
umlegen das ist natürlich erst mal ihr
recht wir werden nicht hingehen und
irgendeinem menschen hier was
vorschreiben
in den islamischen ländern wird es wohl
geschrieben wir leben in demokratien
islamisch beherrschten land wissen sie
das gar nicht dass manche länder
islamistisch beherrscht sind also für
dich beuteschaden ockel dass das starten
das ist aber finde ich noch mal was
anderes wie länder in denen es auch
muslime gibt die da leben
die nicht wissen wie eine religion außen
wären nicht an islams vom islamismus gut
gewesen die politisierten islam und also
natürlich das individuum das weibliche
dass hier ein kopftuch trägt es hat auch
frauen haben auch ganz unterschiedliche
motive ja manchmal werden sie von ihrer
familie oder dem ihr benötigt so und so
sagten ja aber manchmal sind sie auch
suchen sie ihre identität frage sich wer
bin ich in diesem land ja und wollen sie
damit zeigen dazu gehöre ich oder sie
wollen innerhalb ihrer gruppe zeigen ich
bin eine anständige frau also weiter es
gibt übrigens frauen
die legen das kopftuch an und sie legen
sie auch wieder ab und ich kann ihnen
zum beispiel dank einer großen
langzeituntersuchung des
innenministeriums in deutschland mit
zehntausenden von menschen sagen 80
prozent der strenggläubigen muslimen in
deutschland haben noch nie ein kopftuch
getragen also das kopftuch es sich eine
frage des glaubens sondern eine frage
der sitten und das kopftuch ist übrigens
dieses kopftuch in unseren ländern 0 wir
haben seit den 60er jahren türken in
deutschland
da haben sie kein kopftuch gesehen da
kam die bäuerin aus anatolien wie gesagt
wir hatte wie die bäuerin aus bayern ein
kopftuch oder das ist ein politisches
signal und darüber müssen wir reden
können und es hat in der schule nichts
zu suchen
frankreich hat es mit erfolg verboten in
der schule und es hat in öffentlichen
institutionen nichts zu suchen
das sehe ich komplett anders aber
darüber klarheit was ist mir schon klar
nur was ich sehe ist warum man auch da
wiederum nicht stärker differenzieren
kann also wir sprechen jetzt nicht über
eine burka die den körper ganz verhüllt
bis auf einen kleinen schlitz für die
augen sondern sprechen einfach über ein
kopftuch und die schwierigkeit finde ich
immer wo beginnt eigentlich eine form
von hilfeleistungen die die
selbstbestimmung einer frau dann wieder
untergräbt was er auf gar keinen fall
ihr ziel sein kann dass man sich
bestimmt auch also die linie
die linie verläuft jetzt immer gleich
zwischen und beiden und sie sind ja auch
nicht die einzige so argumentieren es
ganz interessant
sie sind dafür dass frauen sich
freiwillig prostituieren können sie sind
dafür dass frauen sich freiwillig
verhüllen regen nicht vermuten kopftuch
wir reden vom islamistischen dass die
haare und körper verdecktes brauchen wir
gar nicht weiter reden also die burka
nein wenn sie wissen sie sich was ein
islamistisches kopftuch ist verflucht
das ist das wo kein haar vorgaben und im
außerdem man noch einen möglichst ein
mantel an hat oder etwas was den körper
verdeckt also wo man nicht seine fatalen
weiblichen reize die nur einen gehören
nämlich dem eigenen mann und die man nur
im haus enthüllen enthüllen darf zeigt
so wie sie sie finden das ist also von
mir recht dogmatisch und streng und
bevormunden und ich kann ihnen nur sagen
es ist traurig dass wir an so einer
linie entlang diskutieren weil die
fahnen sind groß und die da den
frauenrollen und sie sehr waren
natürlich gut reden sie sind
privilegiert sie das ist mir vollkommen
klar
ich finde aber auch ganz wichtig dass
wir was wir sehen was hier gerade
passiert wir sind im gespräch und ich
versuche situation natürlich weil ich
weil ich einfach glaube es geht
natürlich um ganz wichtige themen auf
den tisch bringen ich fahre hier sind
ihnen ja auch sehr viele freiwillig aber
wissen sie bei einer bestimmten art von
provokation bleiben wir mal stecken auf
einen ziemlich oberflächlichen ebene
antwort es wäre viel interessanter ins
differenzierte zu gehen zum beispiel bei
der prostitution hätte mich im gespräch
mit ihnen interessiert jetzt viel mehr
ist doch klar dass prostitution ein übel
ist interessant wer gewesen ist das denn
wirklich sinnvoll die feier bestrafung
zu fördern
da sind wir jetzt da und nicht bei dem
immer gleich nach halben dutzend in
deutschland halbes dutzend straßen haben
wir vielleicht auch ein halbes dutzend
schwarz propagandist innen die meisten
studio betreiberin sind edel passieren
lassen sie sagen nicht gern sehen was
dann sagen sie mir was da zu sein
im postiert mich ist eigentlich nicht
mehr wir haben ganz viel über jede
glaube sie haben doch gerade sie haben
doch gerade gesagt aber wir haben die
sache brechen warum warum ist verkehrt
sein könnte die freiheit zwischen ich
warum es fehlt sein könnte ich meine das
ist eine an das ist eine interessante
kontroverse ja und ich zum beispiel kann
ihnen auch nicht alle antworten geben
wir noch anstalten gerade weil er ja das
ist auch falsch oder nein ich gehe nicht
gerne rezepte und ich gebe auch nicht
gerne und ich bin ganz angeht da ich bin
wirklich für die für eine echte freiheit
des menschen aber nicht für eine
verinnerlichte geschichte die zur
selbstzerstörung führt in freiheit für
sie frau schwarzer was sind wir
vielleicht wird ja ich wähle ich glaube
ja also ich 1971 über mein erstes buch
gemacht habe und zwar über die über die
gegen die gründe und die folgen des von
wegen position des abtreibungsverbots da
ist einer meiner letzten sätze gewesen
ich bin zwar wird das recht von frauen
auf abtreibung und das recht auf
medizinische hilfe ohne bevormundung nur
darum geht es ja ich bin ja nicht für
abtreibungen gottes willen ich bin
einfach nur dafür dass frauen die frauen
die ungewollt schwanger sind die auf
keinen fall werden wollen
das team nicht zu enge macherin gehen
müssen sich nicht demütigen lassen
müssen sich nicht bevormunden lassen
sondern dass die medizinische hilfe
bekommen und schloss so und da ist einer
meiner letzten sätze gewesen mir ist
klar dass dieses recht auch missbraucht
werden kann
jedes recht ist missbrauch war das also
wenn man die freiheit hat abzutreiben
das vielleicht sogar wenig bewusste
frauen mal ein bisschen sehr
leichtsinnig einfach schwanger werden
oder schwangerer männer zu ihnen sagen
kein wunder also abtreiben so
freiwilligkeit geht hand in hand auch
mit einem bewusstsein und mit einem
wissen um die dinge was man da tut
das ist absolut richtige heiligen
detaillierte information vorraum jahre
haft
begreifen nicht nur information nicht
nur statistiken und für vieles braucht
auch gar keine statistiken wenn ich ihn
einfach den dingen nach senioren nach
bei der prostitution vergessen sie also
vielleicht ist das der grund diesmal
diesem in diesem letzten ma heft im
neuesten geht es ja um mitgefühl habe
ich mich dann gefragt vielleicht des
passen stück weiter schlüssel recht für
sie dass sie sagen würden es geht gar
nicht so sehr um argumente sondern um
einfühlung ist was die punkte ja auch ja
der titel ist das thema ist kein zufall
dass wir in diesem thema
wissenschaftlich mitgefühl wie ist das
leben im steht mit gefühl und kann man
mitgefühl lernen und was in der tat
ich denke dass es an mitgefühl fehlt
wissen sie ich bin ja die politische
generation die schon irgendwie dachte
die welt verbessern und alles besser und
und es gibt viele menschen deren
schlechter geht und das muss sich ändern
also für uns war mitgefühl
selbstverständlich und das ist allgemein
politisch nicht mehr so das ist nicht
nur im feminismus so im wort die
karriere wir ja vorher verpönt gewesen
jetzt ist das für viele die sich für
firmen ist inhalten das einzige ich bin
total dafür dass raum karriere machen
und ich finde toll wenn sie tüchtig sind
nur bitte schön auch mal über die
eigenen interessen hinaus denken und
sich einfühlen man muss einfach nur
hingucken
gehen sie mal gehen sie mal deine ihrer
verrichtungsboxen und gucken sie den
frauen meine augen
wir haben mit macht angefangen die
höheren mit mitgefühl das doch schön ja
das ist sehr schön ich danke ihnen frau
[Musik]
das gespräch mit alice schwarzer steht
ihnen ab sofort bequem im internet zur
verfügung
haben sie auch schon mal von sexual
begleitung für behinderte menschen
gehört wir müssen da die grenzen zur
prostitution gezogen werden
unser junger kollege oliver del fabro
äußert sich dazu auf der kulturplattform
thema nächsten sonntag in der
sternstunde philosophie hermann burger
einer der verlorenen schriftsteller der
schweiz ein virtuoser dazu wir gedenken
seiner anlässlich seines 25 todestags
und jetzt jetzt geht es um aufruhr zwei
jahre arbeitslager für eine minute
provokation die frauen von passiert
mussten für ihr protest gebet hart
bezahlt ein film zeichnet die geschichte
der performance-gruppe nach